[Música]
quien controla el capitalismo mundial
todos habéis oído hablar de la
conspiración reptiliana los rothschild o
george soros
[Música]
pero hay un actor aún más importante en
el que prácticamente nadie repara
[Música]
el gobierno de noruega
[Aplausos]
[Música]
noruega no solo es uno de los países más
ricos del mundo sino también uno de los
más influyentes en las finanzas
internacionales
[Música]
[Aplausos]
creéis que nos hemos vuelto locos para
nada al final de este vídeo lo
entenderéis todo
[Aplausos]
[Música]
noruega es el único país del mundo donde
el black metal satánico se considera un
género de música comercial es decir que
si tú vas a noruega y poner la radio lo
más probable es que no suene maluma sino
bandas como word war of my head o lily
master y su mega he titulado mayas lo
cierto es que noruega es uno de los
países más ricos del mundo al mismo
nivel que suiza o irlanda pero no sólo
eso también es uno de los más
igualitarios del planeta es decir con
menos diferencias entre ricos y pobres
[Música]
tienen uno de los estados del bienestar
más generosos que existen un nivel de
vida envidiable y además es el país
donde se educó el rubio amo y señor de
youtube hispanoparlante pero todo esto
ya lo sabéis sin embargo la sombra de
noruega es mucho más alargada hablamos
de uno de los actores con más poder en
el capitalismo mundial
[Música]
tal vez usted no lo sepa pero el
gobierno de noruega está en la
trastienda de las principales
corporaciones de nuestro planeta
vale vale no os vayáis todavía ya sé lo
que estáis pensando y no este vídeo no
es una colaboración con mundo
desconocido veréis noruega tiene una
población que a duras penas llega a los
5 millones de habitantes es decir que
hasta el área metropolitana de madrid
está más poblado sin embargo estos 5
millones de habitantes son accionistas
de las principales empresas del mundo
tal cual como lo es el gobierno de
noruega tiene uno de los mayores fondos
de inversiones del mundo con acciones en
casi todas las empresas es probable que
sin saberlo el rubio tenga acciones en
compañías como apple facebook o tesla
usted no lo sabe
y francamente yo tampoco no sabemos si
el rubio tributa noruega así que
pero la pregunta que si podemos
contestar es porque noruega es tan rico
como han llegado hasta aquí a estas
alturas muchos estaréis pensando en una
palabra petróleo
efectivamente noruega es uno de los
mayores productores de zumo de
dinosaurio del mundo sin embargo no se
parecen en nada al resto de países
petroleros por ejemplo fijaos en esta
foto del skyline de riad la capital de
arabia saudita
[Música]
parece una ciudad de ciencia ficción
verdad rascacielos edificios ultra
modernos y montones de lucecitas y ahora
mira de esta otra de oslo la capital de
noruega
[Música]
creo que empezáis a notar las
diferencias verdad si seguís visual
polític desde hace tiempo ya sabéis que
tener petróleo no es sinónimo de ser
rico es más como podéis ver en esta
gráfica el crudo noruego es dos veces
más caro de extraer que por ejemplo el
saudí
[Música]
para que os hagáis una idea la mayor
parte del petróleo noruego viene de los
yacimientos que hay en el mar del norte
y esos yacimientos los comparte junto
con otros países como reino unido sin
embargo no lo haga ha sido el país que
más rendimiento ha sacado al petróleo
del mar del norte y ya sé lo que
estaréis pensando otro vídeo más de
visual polític donde nos cuentan como
noruega se volvió rica privatizando
empresas pues nada de eso noruega es un
ejemplo del libro de lo que podríamos
llamar capitalismo de estado
así que por quién noruega es tan rica
porque son tan influyentes en la
economía internacional que significa que
un gobierno invierta en bolsa hoy vamos
a responder a estas preguntas pero antes
vamos a ver un poco de historia
[Música]
enfermedad holandesa tenemos que ser
honestos noruega nunca ha sido un país
especialmente pobre pero tampoco
especialmente rico en los años 50 los
noruegos tenían un nivel de vida similar
al de los franceses
esto significa que eran más ricos que
los españoles pero muy por debajo de sus
vecinos suecos o por supuesto los
estadounidenses por aquel entonces nadie
pensaba que noruega pudiera tener
petróleo pero las cosas cambiaron en el
año 1959 y en ese momento es cuando se
le empezó sus prospecciones en el mar
del norte cell es la petrolera de países
bajos y estaba buscando posibles
yacimientos en las costas de su país
y eureka encontraron unas pequeñas
bolsas de gas si hay gas tiene que haber
petróleo cerca así que continuaron con
las prospecciones y así es como
descubrieron uno de los mayores
yacimientos de petróleo en el mundo un
yacimiento que está en las aguas del
reino unido y noruega durante los años
sesentas él consiguió licencias de
explotación en estos dos países
años más tarde en 1972 el gobierno de
noruega creó su propia empresa de
petróleo
statoil y así es como estalló el petró
boom del mar del norte
de estado durante los años 70 el dinero
entraba en noruega a calderadas y en
sólo tres años duplicaron su renta per
cápita de repente el sueño de todo
noruego era trabajar en esa pujante
industria del zumo de dinosaurio quien
quiere pescar salmones cuando puede
forrar
trabajando en el petróleo suena
fantástico verdad
e
bueno
pues no a este fenómeno se le conoce
como la enfermedad holandesa o maldición
de los recursos naturales
[Música]
básicamente cada vez que un país se
encuentra petróleo la economía se vuelve
loca el gobierno se puede permitir
despilfarrar el dinero y bajar los
impuestos y todos los ciudadanos quieren
trabajar en el sector del petróleo que
para algo es el más rentable conclusión
en pocos años tu economía solo produce
un producto petróleo y en el momento en
el cual baja el precio del barril el
país entero se va a pique lo hemos visto
en venezuela lo estamos viendo en arabia
saudita y lo estamos viendo también en
bahrein y aquí es donde llega la gran
diferencia de actitud entre noruega y
reino unido-
[Música]
ambos países tenían gobiernos laboristas
pero sus posiciones no podían ser más
distintas en 1976 reino unido- estaba en
mitad de una de sus peores crisis
económicas así que el gobierno estaba
deseando exprimir al máximo todo el
potencial del mar del norte noruega sin
embargo tenía una situación mucho más
estable y podían permitirse esperar pero
hoy esto qué significa pues primero que
el gobierno puso unas regulaciones muy
estrictas a la industria por un lado el
50 por ciento de todas las explotaciones
de petróleo tiene que estar en manos de
esta torre
[Música]
el otro las petroleras extranjeras
tenían que pagar un 78 por ciento de
impuestos sobre los beneficios en el
país pero aquí no termina la cosa el
gobierno noruego puso toda clase de
límites a la producción de zumo de
dinosaurio fijaos en esta gráfica aquí
podéis ver cómo reino unido-- dispara o
su producción desde el primer momento a
finales de los años 70 los británicos ya
producían más de millón y medio de
barriles al día mientras que noruega no
llegaba ni a la tercera parte
[Música]
durante los años 80 ya con el gobierno
de margaret thatcher
reino unido continúa exprimiendo zumo de
dinosaurio como si no existiera mañana
mientras que noruega sigue tomándose lo
con calma que conseguían con esto pues
desincentivar que todas las fuerzas
productivas del país se volcarán en el
petróleo
pero esperado otro momento porque hay
otra gran diferencia entre noruega y
reino unido- veréis en los años 80 el
gobierno de margaret thatcher privatizó
british petroleum sin embargo el
gobierno noruego siempre ha mantenido el
control sobre statoil hoy en día están
doyle ha cambiado de nombre y ahora se
llama equinos pero el gobierno sigue
teniendo el 67 por ciento de la
propiedad de la empresa y ya se lo que
estáis pensando oh dios mío noruega es
un país socialista bueno más bien
podríamos comparar su sistema económico
con el de china muchos teóricos lo
llaman capitalismo de estado es decir
aunque el estado controla una buena
parte de la economía se comporta como si
fuera una empresa privada y esto qué
significa pues ahora mismo lo vamos a
ver
[Música]
[Aplausos]
el país que invierte en bolsa antes de
empezar tengo que hacer un paréntesis
porque estos acordes tan bonitos y
dulces que están sonando son la música
de ender un grupo de black metal de
colombia y os lo recomiendo
encarecidamente si os gusta el género
veréis que no tienen nada que envidiarle
a ninguna banda noruega y es que mira
qué bonito suena a ver si aprendes mal
um
[Aplausos]
volviendo a nuestra historia recordáis
esas dos fotos que os ponía al principio
del vídeo otros países como arabia
saudita han aprovechado esos pingües
benefícios del zumo de dinosaurio para
gastar cual estrella de hip-hop en un
viernes por la tarde sin embargo los
distintos gobiernos tanto laboristas
como conservadores han continuado
midiendo hasta el último céntimo que se
gastan y todo esto que significa pues
que todo ese dinero que ganaban con las
ventas del crudo se guardaba en una
hucha y así es como llegamos al año 1990
en ese momento el parlamento noruego se
da cuenta de que tiene un montón de
dinero ahorrado que el precio del
petróleo puede subir o bajar dependiendo
del mercado internacional y que lo mejor
que pueden hacer es diversificar su
economía aún más y qué mejor forma para
hacerlo que invertir en bolsa pues como
decimos en visual político dicho y hecho
[Aplausos]
así es como nació el fondo de pensiones
noruego también conocido como el fondo
soberano noruego es decir que el banco
central de noruega controla su propio
fondo de inversiones
y si ya sé lo que estaréis pensando
muchos un fondo soberano bueno hay
muchos otros países que también tienen
fondos soberanos y tenéis razón el
gobierno chino también invierte en
empresas y australia y emiratos árabes
unidos entonces qué tiene de especial
este fondo soberano noruego pues de
entrada el tamaño para que os hagáis una
idea este fondo de inversiones tiene más
de un billón de dólares estadounidenses
y si he dicho billón en castellano en
inglés sería trillón es decir que si lo
repartimos entre todos los ciudadanos
noruegos toca a casi doscientos mil
dólares por persona si lo ha escuchado
perfectamente bien eso significa que si
el rubio siguiera siendo ciudadano
noruego tiene más de 200 mil dólares
invertidos en bolsa
ah
pero aquí no termina la cosa veréis
según la ley noruega nadie puede tocar
ese dinero para gasto público es decir
que el gobierno noruego solo puede
utilizar los beneficios que da este
fondo pero no el capital invertido y
creedme no hablamos de una propia
[Aplausos]
como el fondo soberano noruego ganó 130
mil millones de dólares en un año
hablamos de uno de los mayores fondos de
inversión de todo el mundo y por ley
sólo pueden invertir en empresas
extranjeras y por eso a día de hoy
tienen el 1,5 por ciento de las acciones
que existen en las bolsas de todo el
mundo por supuesto como en todos los
fondos de inversiones hay años peores y
años mejores según muchos analistas las
estrategias en este fondo son demasiado
conservadoras y en muchos casos no dan
todo el beneficio que deberían pero lo
cierto es que noruega no solo utiliza
este dinero para diversificar su
economía también es un arma política
e
el fondo del petróleo noruego con 905
mil millones de dólares saca su músculo
en el accionariado el fondo soberano más
grande del mundo se ha puesto a 6.700
decisiones de empresas el año pasado
pérez por un lado el banco central
noruego publica todos los años una lista
negra con todas las empresas donde no
invierten por razones éticas eso incluye
a empresas de armas de tabaco o que
tengan algún tipo de caso de corrupción
pero eso es sólo el principio veréis
tener acciones de una empresa no sólo es
una forma de ganar o perder dinero
también te da derecho a participar en
las juntas de accionistas y cuantas más
acciones tengas más importante es tu
voto en las decisiones de esa empresa
[Música]
por ejemplo desde verano de 2018
facebook se está empezando a tomar en
serio los algoritmos que detectan las
fake news también están empezando a
reducir la brecha salarial entre hombres
y mujeres pues bien estas dos decisiones
son fruto de un consejo de accionistas
que se celebró en verano de 2018 y quien
puso esos temas encima de la mesa
exacto noruega y lo mismo ocurre con
otras empresas
[Música]
noruega apoya la postura de los
activistas en las reuniones de alphatec
como ya sabéis alphabet es la empresa
matriz de google pues bien una serie de
accionistas minoritarios querían que
google refinar el filtro de pequeños y
lo mismo pueden decir en apple en este
caso noruega es el octavo accionista
mayoritario con más de 8 mil millones de
euros invertidos y tampoco se callan en
sus reuniones de activistas en general
noruega está empujando a que las grandes
empresas del mundo entero cambien sus
políticas en muchos frentes por supuesto
está a la brecha de género pero no sólo
eso parte de lo que podríamos llamar la
ideología noruega incluye cosas como
esta
[Música]
el fondo soberano noruego se centra en
los altos sueldos de los ejecutivos
exacto en muchos casos los ejecutivos de
las grandes multinacionales cobran
sueldos millonarios pese a que la
empresa esté en pérdidas lo hemos visto
con muchos de los bancos que casi se
arruinan durante la crisis financiera
como os podéis imaginar a los
accionistas de estas empresas es decir a
los capitalistas no les hace ninguna
gracia pero es difícil alzar la voz
cuando tienes solamente unas pocas
acciones pues bien noruego de actúa como
gran altavoz de todos esos inversores
barra activistas que no sólo quieren
ganar el dinero sino también cambiar el
modo en el que se dirigen las grandes
compañías en visual política hemos
hablado muchas veces de como un gobierno
intenta influir en otro gobierno pero en
este caso se trata de un gobierno
influyendo en las empresas de todo el
mundo mientras tanto los noruegos pueden
vivir tranquilos con un fondo soberano
tan extremadamente diversificado saben
que aunque el petróleo caiga tienen su
futuro asegurado
[Música]
y ahora la pregunta es para vosotros
creéis que es buena idea el hecho de que
un estado se meta a invertir en bolsa
hasta qué punto noruega ejerce una buena
o una mala influencia en las empresas
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios y como siempre no olvidéis
que sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las
semanas así que suscribiros a visual
política y darle click a la campanita
para que os llegue una notificación cada
vez que sacamos un vídeo nuevo que os ha
gustado este capítulo dadle a like
compartirlo con vuestros amigos y nos
vemos en el próximo un abrazo y hasta
pronto
[Música]
[Aplausos]